and this is where we begin with the
debate over how and when to begin
reopening this country president Trump
says plans are close to being finalized
and the Washington Post has obtained one
possible road map from the CDC and FEMA
the president has backed off claims have
total authority over such efforts he now
says it will be up to the states
governors the president is also
escalating efforts to cast blame for the
pandemic he says he's withholding u.s.
funding to the World Health Organization
claiming it didn't give the u.s. enough
warning Paula Reid is at the White House
Paula we want to start with the possible
roadmap for reopening the country what
do we know about it good morning Anthony
well The Washington Post has obtained a
draft of this road map and it's divided
into three phases the first phase
focuses on really preparing the country
explaining to people how they should
continue their mitigation efforts and
starting to educate people about how the
government intends to roll some of those
efforts back now the second phase which
will go until about May 15th emphasizes
ramping up manufacturing of testing kits
and also hiring more healthcare support
workers to help with this massive
response but the country doesn't really
start to reopen until phase 3 which
cannot according to this plan begin
before May 1st
but this draft of a strategy comes as
the president continues to send mixed
messages about who exactly gets to
decide when the US is back open for
business
I will then be authorizing each
individual governor of each individual
state to implement a reopening at his
briefing yesterday President Trump made
a dramatic about-face in his ongoing
feud with state governors conceding they
can decide when to open their local
economies the governors are gonna do a
good job and if they don't do a good job
we're gonna come down on them very hard
president Trump promises to issue a
revised social distancing guidelines
soon and said he's singling out over 20
states to reopen first it's going to be
very very close maybe even before the
date of May 1st but in an interview with
these
ciated press dr. Anthony Falchi who
wasn't at the briefing yesterday said
that target is a bit overly optimistic
as the US does not yet have the critical
testing and tracing procedures needed to
begin reopening the nation's economy we
have to have something in place that is
efficient and that we can rely on and
we're not there yet the president seemed
to dismiss his point the president also
announced he will suspend funding for
the World Health Organization the
international body which is coordinating
the global fight against this pandemic
through actions like shipping
life-saving medical supplies to 95
countries the reality is that the w-h-o
failed to adequately obtain vet and
share information in a timely and
transparent fashion the president claims
the outbreak could have been contained
in China if the organization had
objectively addressed the situation
instead of taking China's reporting at
face values but even after the group
declared a health emergency on January
30th more than a week later the
president was saying this about China
well I think China is very you know
professionally run in the sense that
they have everything under control and
with a massive trade deal hanging in the
balance the president still appears
unwilling to directly confront China
China's transparency
president Trump is not the only one who
has criticized the WHS response to
coronavirus but the only American
scientists who were allowed into China
to study this virus when as part of a
w-h-o team and earlier this week the
director of the CDC described the
organization as a quote important public
health partner last year the u.s.
contributed about 450 million dollars to
the w-h-o they overall have about a six
billion dollar budget Anthony oh thank
you